the beat of a final wave of adulation
for Edison nasamento better known to the
world as Pele
fans of Santos
the club and town where he spent almost
all of his playing days were gathered to
cheer him on for his final Journey
from Villa belmiro Stadium where he
first arrived as a callow 16 year old to
the Town Cemetery where he'll rest as an
82 year old Legend
thousands more had already passed by his
open casket inside the stadium during a
24-hour wake
new president Luis Ignacio Lula was
among the last of them arriving by
helicopter from Sao Paulo
Clayton motor had a longer Journey 14
hours by bus from his home in minus
gerais the state where Pele was also
born
just for this a chance to see the
coughing go by
asked him why especially as like the
majority of people here he'd been born
too late to see Pele in his prime
when we were children Brazilians were
disappointed with politics the economy
and everything in the country and pelia
was the first black person to be
successful in Brazil he was very
respected everywhere he went in the
world Pele seemed to belong to the
Brazilian people and then the world a
Serial winner with a wide smile and
humble demeanor flashed across TVs in
Technicolor during the 1970 World Cup
whether he was with from movie stars to
U.S presidents you probably are aware of
who are with me here today oh by the way
my name is Ronald Reagan he would almost
always be the most famous person in the
room
but for many saying goodbye in the town
of Santos the connection was less
starry-eyed more intimate milk
my father who unfortunately can't be
here today because he passed away was a
big supporter of Santos and was friends
with pillow with Peppa coutinho Zito
Lima he was great friends with them all
and I decided along with my daughter and
my mum to come here to represent my
father because if he was alive he would
definitely be here paying his homage to
Pella the funeral procession took four
hours to wind through Santos and to get
here to the town's vertical Cemetery
just under a kilometer away
but they have wanted to be placed on the
ninth floor because nine is the number
that his dad dondino also a footballer
had on the back of his shirt but his
family actually changed that when he
died and decided to put him on the first
floor instead because they wanted him to
be more accessible to the fans and
people that wanted to come and visit him
this it seems will be the new Shrine for
Pele in a country that still reveres him
John Holman Al Jazeera Santos